contrary to this new movement about ideas
and dialogue and platforming and hearing everything
everybody
out.
I think it's important at some point to insert
what should be a pretty obvious reality to
us, which is that no matter what conversations
you want to have or you choose to have or
you enable the having of, you can't find middle
ground with crazy people.
Not every idea deserves to be part of the
discussion.
Not every person can be part of the solution
and some people and their ideas have to be
ignored, have to be kept out of the discussion
or we are going to truly damage ourselves
as a species, as a human society, as a country.
However you want to slice and dice it.
Now before people go crazy and start writing
in saying, David, you're calling for censorship.
You're calling for mistreatment of people.
You are limiting people's first amendment
rights and limiting what people have to say.
I'm not okay.
This came up last week during the interview
I did with Joe Rogan in Los Angeles.
There's lots of great things about this movement
of the last several years that says it wants
to hear all ideas and it wants to figure out
what's best than have in depth discussion
was with people from all sides of the political
spectrum.
That's great.
Okay.
I've been doing it for 10 years on the show.
Dialogue is good.
Discourse is critical to human advancement.
A diverse range of opinions should be heard
and considered and evaluated.
When we are trying to figure out as humans
what is best for our future and what's best
for our societies, but there are people out
there with outrageously extreme bad ideas
and it's okay to put the line somewhere and
say, you don't get a seat at the table.
We're going to figure this thing out without
you because your ideas are terrible and crazy
and dangerous in some cases.
Now, of course the devil is in the details
and who is it that gates gets that sort of
gatekeeping power?
That's a real question, but during the Joe
Rogan interview, I pointed out I'm one of
the biggest advocates of conversations with
people.
We disagree with.
Respectful debate, the marketplace of ideas,
responsible platforming of extremism even,
but that at a certain point you can't have
reasonable conversations with some people.
I gave the example if we're trying to figure
out what the top marginal tax rate should
be in modern western countries like ours that
have economic systems that depend on government
revenue already, what role is there for someone
who thinks all taxes are government slavery,
right?
You have to do the responsible and not give
that person a seat at the table when it comes
down to actually making policy, okay, you
want to do a TV show and have someone from
the taxes or slavery camp do it.
You want to have an academic debate about
taxation, bring the taxes or slavery people,
but when we're trying to figure this out in
the serious legislative sense, does that person
demand or or rather deserve a seat at the
table?
No, it's just an interruption.
It's going to get in the way of actually figuring
things out when we're trying to figure out
the issue of it being legal still now in 2019
in a bunch of states to fire people based
on their sexual orientation, real or perceived
sexual orientation.
Should a lawmaker or a voter who believes
that gay people should be put to death have
a seat at the table in that conversation?
No.
It would be irresponsible.
It would be ridiculous to give that person
a seat at the table.
There's nothing wrong with this.
Okay.
It's called modern society in philosophy.
There's something called The Hague alien dialectic.
It's named after Hagle, a German philosopher
from the late 18th early 19th century, and
the basic idea of the huggy alien dialectic
is that the process of change comes from the
process of figuring things out, maybe is a
better way of saying it.
It comes from a thesis and then an anti thesis
or an antithesis and then a synthesis of the
two into some kind of path forward.
The underlying idea is that we're constantly
merging opposed ideologies that will get us
closer to an ideal or a solution or perfection
of some kind to use a utopian idealistic term.
This doesn't work with outrageous, bad faith,
ignorant or cognitively limited people and
horrible ideas, period.
We need to stop going so far into the marketplace
of ideas to the point where it becomes self
destructed by destructive.
Rather.
When we mandate that all ideas be considered
equally and given equal footing, we are actually
seeding ground to extremism.
And this is not a hypothetical.
This is how the right has won many victories.
If eventually the solution is going to end
up as the midpoint or the average or the mean
of all ideas by presenting the most extreme
possible ideas, you pull the average to your
side.
Republicans know this, the right node, this
knows this and they've used it successfully.
If the debate over abortion, uh, is about
up until what point in a pregnancy should
abortion be legal?
And we sort of concede that we're going to
end up in the middle of all of the suggestions
that we get.
The antiabortion right is incentivize to straight
up say all abortions should be illegal at
one day of pregnancy.
Abortion is illegal.
And if we guarantee that crazy position a
seat at the table, they win by suggesting
the craziest possible idea and pulling the
Overton window, pulling the average of the
debate over to their side.
If the debate over the highest marginal tax
rate is going to end up as the average of
all the proposed ideas, the right benefits
by saying the tax rate should be zero or taxation
is slavery because it pulls the average towards
them.
I wished Democrats had understood this longer
ago if they had decided not to seed a ton
of ground to republicans trying to negotiate
over things that Republicans simply will not
negotiate about.
We would be far better off today.
Uh, if you do a show and you want to hear
out wacky ideas, do it.
I do it on this show as long as I'm prepared
to responsibly do it, pushing back against
them, giving an opposing view.
But when we're trying to have the serious
conversations, we don't have any responsibility
to let just any crazy old notion into the
discussion.
When a new plane is being developed, there
is a cutoff as to what ideas of Boeing or
Airbus allow into the discussion and who is
allowed to contribute to the plains design.
Anything else?
We'd be ridiculous when we consider the best
treatment for a medical condition.
Not every crazy notion is given the same value.
This is logical.
It shouldn't be different with politics.
This isn't censorship.
Everyone can say whatever they want.
Say It on Youtube, go to your local city council
meeting and say it, write a letter, uh, to
your elected officials, do a podcast, whatever,
but you can't negotiate with crazy people
and their crazy ideas and they don't have
to be given a seat at the big boy table.
And that's okay.
Period.
Let me know if you disagree.